well the small business minister paul
scully is here with me very good morning
to you and so much to talk about this
morning but i do want to kick off uh
with more travel chaos as we're
outlining this morning at the boss of
heathrow airport as you heard there
saying that that kind of disruption
could last for 18 months at gatwick
airport reducing the number of flights
over the summer period
should airports have been better
prepared
well i think we knew that the uh the
travel industry as a whole was already
really hard pressed through covid and as
you heard john honkay there say that
when you start up anything almost from
scratch because there were very very few
fights going through heathrow at some
points that it takes time to come
through and re and upskill
um the staff bring the staff back in so
our ministers transport ministers have
been trying to work with um heathrow
gatwick or the other airport operators
we do want them to do more we want to
make sure that in a tight labor market
there are enough people to uh to staff
the roles there and we'll continue to
work with them but you've got sympathy
with them you think that they couldn't
have planned this any better well i'm
not on the detail in terms of their
day-to-day planning as a business
minister rather than a
a transport minister but uh but it is it
is difficult we've seen this in other
sectors to the that idea of scaling up
again having had uh almost mothballed
the economy for two years um but in in
travel and airports it's so so important
because not only do you we need to
reinstall investment and travel from
international travel coming in but as
you say there's that pent up demand for
people to go as you go out for the first
time there's so much demand i mean
people have had a miserable time haven't
they for many people this is their first
holiday they've had for years and if
they have the prospect of it being
cancelled and having to rebook
with inflation at a at
nine percent at the moment they're gonna
have to pay more for another holiday so
what can the government do to help well
this is why we want to work really
closely with the airports andy and the
um the airlines as well to make sure
that they are doing everything they can
and and see what more we can do from uh
organizations of the department for
working pensions our work coaches to
make sure that in a tight labor market
where people um can work more hours if
they if they're able to uh and really
matching up so that's the answer is that
people have to just work hard
well
what i mean is that the uh there are a
record number of vacancies 1.3 million
vacancies across the country in all
manner of sectors but um there are also
people who have recalibrated what they
want to do when they're on furlough and
we want to make sure that those people
that are not necessarily working
full-time um
through universal credit we can we can
get them back in to to work to be more
productive if that if that suits them
and obviously match them up with it with
the sectors where there are with those
vacancies okay it sounds like you are
saying you want people to work longer
hours and well
we're not talking about going out and
forcing people to do anything but they
just want to make sure that they're
matched up properly so that it's just
got
that those people who can work longer
that want to work longer can work can be
better matched with the work coaches and
work closely with their work coaches how
bad is this going to get we saw the bank
of england raising interest rates for
the fifth consecutive month a warning of
more rises ahead inflation they say
could go up to 11
how bad is the situation are we heading
for a recession well i think what you
what we are saying we do we're trying to
do everything we can to tackle the cost
of living uh issues this is a global
situation you've seen inflation in other
countries in america and other european
countries um hitting similarly high
figures and and forecast so we've got to
do everything we can to weather that
storm
the chancellor has put in 37 billion
pounds worth of um support and what
you'll see that um the 650 million
pounds is going to a number of um
households will be hitting their bank
accounts on the 14th of july it's not
enough though you'll see the national
insurance threshold changes actually
giving it delivering a tax cut next
month as well so we we know about that
package but there needs to be an overall
economic strategy doesn't there i mean
these these changes obviously will will
make a bit of a difference but not
enough of a difference
what you saw the chance to do throughout
um kovid you saw him flex as as he saw
what was happening on the ground the
feedback that was coming back and uh
and tackling the very best data and
forecasts and he's doing a similar thing
now as i said he's put 37 billion pounds
worth of immediate relief to especially
for the most vulnerable in our society
anything we need to do fiscally around
tax uh tax changes that that that gets
done in the autumn budget so that
there's
we'll make sure that we're listening
looking and responding
what about help for people with
mortgages i mean they're saying interest
rates go up is there anything that you
can do to help people out who are on
variable mortgages or looking to buy a
house and get a new mortgage well i
think in terms of uh you know buying a
house and
and taking up new mortgages people need
to obviously
do do their own calculations and and
work with what they can what what they
can afford but as i say in terms of
existing householders and uh and
people's everyday bills the chancellor
will look and respond accordingly what
we can't do the government he's already
said he's absolutely right the
government can't solve every problem
within this it's not going to be able to
save every business and and work with
everybody's uh individual costs but
we'll do everything we can within that
within the remit of keeping public
finances um tight as well because we're
actually servicing our debt national
debt having just put 480 billion
eight billion pounds into the economy
we're paying something like 85 billion
pounds just to service our debt not to
go to schools hospitals we've got to
keep that running as well yes and a lot
of people think about their own personal
debt of course what about tax cuts i
mean this just isn't the environment for
tax cuts is it with inflation looking
like it could reach 11 well that's what
i mean about the chancellor looking at
everything holistically so come the next
budget he will have to look at the
balance but what do you think should
happen richie sunaka said that the tax
cuts aren't on the cards now do you
think that's the right i i think you
know we are a low tax government i would
like to see taxes
tax government at the moment well no
because we i say we've just put 408
billion pounds into the economy you know
that's my general principle and the
party's general principle is to have low
taxes to trust people to spend their own
money the best way we can but as i say
we've got to keep the nhs we're going to
get the backlog dealt with in the nhs
we've got to keep our schools well
funded all of those um those things in
the finance public finances it's a
complex situation and having put all
that money in
the chancellor can look when it comes to
the budget and make his decision at that
point
but you think
no tax cuts is the right way forward for
now well what i don't want to do is
write a budget months ahead of the uh of
a budget i'm just no announcements on
tax cuts there won't be tax cuts now
because as i say that will be any taxes
that are dealt with a budget in the
autumn there's so much so much to go
until we get to the autumn and you know
things can change in any number of ways
okay i want to to move on to the
resignation of lord guide and boris
johnson's ethics advisor
he released his or rather the government
released his resignation letter
yesterday
can you say in the light of that without
doubt that you believe that the prime
minister boris johnson is a man who
upholds the highest standards required
of his office
yeah i i can i think he's been clear in
um
in his approach and uh
uh regarded to the fine that he received
i think lord guyt um seemed to have
resigned on um
the discussion around when the prime
minister asked him for advice for um uh
for supporting
uh our industries in the in in the next
few months at the steel industry just to
be to clarify well that's that's what i
understand from the letter just see
reading the letter i've not been part of
uh of the discussion but i read the
letters as they were released that was
my understanding about it now clearly
those kind of discussions if there
aren't
you know i wouldn't want to speculate
because that's obviously commercially
sensitive stuff but uh um but but that's
i i have no more knowledge than that but
that seems to be where lord guy is
finally taking his decision but
nonetheless in terms of the prime
minister's behavior you know he
uh rightly wants to draw a line under
the the so-called party gate because
people are
uh worried more about what you've just
been talking about the cost of living
the what's going to mean to their
mortgages and their bills um in the in
the days and months ahead they want to
feel that their prime minister is
ethical too don't they and
how
will they view the fact that he's lost
two ethics advisors in very quick
succession and lord gait the last one to
go has said in his resignation letter
that the prime minister put him in an
impossible and odious position this
isn't someone who who speaks out in this
kind of language normally
doesn't that point does that point to a
prime minister who's got the highest
ethical standards well i think my
understanding of what i read that when i
read the letter was that that was
talking about uh advice that he'd asked
him to give not not about not about the
impossible
yeah which which i can't really
reconcile my myself because that was
about advice he he's asked him on
something else rather than uh what's
happening around around partygate but in
in terms of the the fine the prime
minister received uh sugray talked about
leadership uh within number 10 and the
cabinet office and there's been a raft
of changes in number 10 and the cabinet
office in terms of organization in terms
of changing that culture changing that
ethos and sugue herself said that she
wants that that needs time to bed in law
guy was clearly very frustrated with the
whole way that that was handled as well
so will there be another ethics advisor
of that i don't know i mean there's a
there's a number of questions that uh
lord guy has has raised about the way
that uh the the way that that system
works and that's right that number 10
actually takes time to just um look at
that and work work that through so um
that'd be for them to announce would
anyone want to do the job it looks like
anyone who does the job is overruled by
the prime minister no well it's as i say
that i think that's that's part of the
uh the the
the consideration is is is how the
system works and uh because we want to
make it um as efficient uh
you know working as as best we can and
um that's what the prime minister number
10 will consider would you be
comfortable if there was no ethics
advisor what kind of message do you
think that would send down what what i
think i would be comfortable with as
long as there is a mechanism there needs
to be a mechanism clearly that the the
prime minister and that me as a minister
are held to the to the highest standards
there is a ministerial code there and we
want to make sure that um that it's
adhered to because that's the principles
that we all stand on not just as mps
when we first come into the house but
when we accept officers of state as
ministers do you think they should go to
parliament do you think this is
something that mps more broadly should
decide on and make sure that there's a
truly independent ethics advisor to keep
the prime minister and the government in
check i think the you know it's
difficult because you then get into
positions where um you know government
government governs and parliament
scrutinizes that parliament would
undoubtedly continue to debate this uh
this matter but i'm not sure that uh
that that day-to-day running of
government
you know the government is beholden to
parliament in that sort of slightly in
in that balance of power as it were
that's so in our unwritten constitution
i'm not sure that's how it works we've
had an extraordinary week in politics
this week haven't we and we've had uh
the bill on the northern ireland
protocol we've had the rwanda policy
seeing uh flights uh grounded
by a court in
in europe
does the prime minister think he can
breach whichever rules he wants and get
away with it because the european
commission vice president uh told our
political editor
that constant breaching of international
law by the country is damaging uk eu
relationships
that i'm afraid just a repeat of sort of
negotiating in public that we've seen
over the last few years i mean i don't
believe uh and the government's been
really clear that uh the legislation
that we've introduced doesn't reach
international law but nonetheless
actually it's there as an insurance
policy anyway what would rather have is
a negotiated settlement with the eu we
don't want to end up in trade wars and
and escalated disputes we want to make
sure that we can work together because
this affects both sides and so if we can
have sensible conversations
um rather than as i say negotiating via
the media or via social media and these
kind of things that's far far better
not just for both sides but for the
businesses that are caught up in this as
well okay paul scully we appreciate your
time this morning thanks very much
indeed for coming in thank you